Selamat kembali ke quantum computing dalam praktik. Episod ini akan fokus pada langkah pertama dan sering yang paling
mencabar dalam mendefinisikan program quantum. Memetakan masalah umum ke circuit yang boleh dijalankan pada komputer quantum.
Langkah ini menerangkan cara pengguna yang bermula dengan masalah pengiraan tertentu
boleh menterjemahkannya supaya komputer quantum boleh faham.
Dalam pelajaran sebelumnya dalam siri ini, pelajaran dua dan tiga, kita bincangkan bahawa peringkat pemetaan adalah langkah pertama daripada
empat dalam rangka kerja Qiskit patterns. Daripada pelajaran-pelajaran tu, korang mungkin ingat matlamat kita adalah untuk menterjemahkan
atau menulis semula masalah pengiraan kepada fungsi kos atau nilai jangkaan
yang boleh kita nilai menggunakan komputer quantum.
Dalam pelajaran tiga, kita bincangkan satu contoh konkrit dengan max cut, masalah
yang sukar secara pengiraan dan biasa dalam pengoptimuman kombinatorial.
Dalam contoh tu, kita melalui beberapa langkah untuk mengubah graf awal kepada masalah yang natif quantum. Kita
mengubah masalah mencari bilangan maksimum potongan dalam graf kepada fungsi kos. kemudian tulis semula fungsi kos tu
sebagai Hamiltonian dan sediakan keadaan quantum percubaan yang keadaan asasnya
sepadan dengan max cut. Akhirnya, kita bina quantum circuit yang mewakili keadaan quantum percubaan yang
diminati dan kemudian tambah gates tertentu untuk membolehkan keadaan berkembang dari masa ke masa. Urutan langkah inilah yang kita
panggil pemetaan. Dan secara umum, prosedur ini umum kepada banyak aplikasi lain seperti kimia quantum
dan simulasi quantum. Sekarang, tak dinafikan pemetaan boleh jadi sukar. Takde
strategi satu-saiz-untuk-semua untuk setiap masalah tunggal, jadi ia boleh menakutkan. Hari ini, saya akan ketengahkan
beberapa contoh masalah yang berbeza dan huraikan cara ia dipetakan dalam setiap kes. Saya akan ringkas
apa yang kita pelajari tentang masalah graf seperti yang digunakan dalam Max Cut dan habiskan baki kuliah fokus
pada cara memetakan masalah yang muncul dalam alam semulajadi seperti masalah struktur molekular dalam biologi, struktur elektronik
dalam kimia dan simulasi teori medan quantum dalam fizik tenaga tinggi.
Tapi sebelum kita habiskan sebahagian besar masa kita dalam episod ini melihat masalah contoh dari literatur, saya nak bagi korang
gambaran keseluruhan peringkat tinggi tentang perkara utama yang kita nak capai dan pertimbangkan bila kita memetakan masalah. Ada
beberapa perkara yang perlu dipertimbangkan untuk sebarang jenis masalah pengiraan yang perlu diterjemahkan kepada quantum circuit.
Pertama, korang mungkin perlu permudahkan masalah untuk membuatnya boleh dilaksanakan. Ini adalah sesuatu yang biasa dalam kebanyakan disiplin saintifik.
Ini bukan unik untuk quantum computing. Kalau korang pernah dengar ungkapan anggap
lembu berbentuk sfera, ia merujuk kepada hakikat bahawa ia sering sukar untuk menerangkan sistem tepat seperti yang kelihatan. Tapi
sebaliknya, kita boleh buat penyederhanaan yang munasabah yang masih boleh membawa kepada penyelesaian yang berguna.
Beberapa contoh cara kita boleh buat ini dalam quantum computing adalah untuk hadkan saiz atau kedalaman circuit dengan memilih
ansatz yang cekap dari segi perkakasan atau memotong evolusi masa yang kompleks atau mengabaikan
sebutan Hamiltonian yang menyumbang sedikit kepada tenaga akhir keadaan quantum.
Perkara seterusnya yang saya nak nyatakan adalah korang kena fikir tentang cara menulis masalah supaya komputer quantum boleh memahaminya.
Selalunya itu melibatkan bertanya tiga soalan ni. Satu, apa yang qubit kita
wakili dalam model ni? Dua, adakah masalah kita berterusan? Memandangkan komputer quantum adalah digital, korang perlu
cari cara untuk mendisretkan masalah. Dan tiga, akhir sekali, adakah topologi masalah sejajar dengan topologi
perkakasan? Kalau ya, bagus. Tapi kalau tidak, kita mungkin perlu laksanakan beberapa trik untuk membuatnya berfungsi. Jadi jom tangani
soalan pertama ni. Apa yang saya fikir adalah inti semua kesukaran dengan memahami pemetaan terutamanya sebagai
konsep baru. Apa yang boleh qubit wakili?
Qubit boleh digunakan untuk mewakili banyak benda. Yang pertama dan paling mudah pada pendapat saya adalah nod pada graf. Graf
digunakan untuk menunjukkan kesambungan dan banyak jenis masalah matematik yang berbeza. Dan nod adalah elemen asas yang mewakili titik
atau entiti dalam rangkaian. Bergantung pada apa yang keseluruhan rangkaian wakili, itu boleh jadi sebuah bandar, orang atau
ferromagnet dalam kekisi. Qubit juga boleh digunakan untuk mewakili boson dan fermion. Walaupun saya perlu beri amaran di sini
bahawa satu qubit tunggal tidak tepat sama dengan satu boson atau satu fermion. Ia sedikit
lebih rumit dari tu dan saya akan masuk ke dalamnya tidak lama lagi, tapi secara umumnya, rantaian spin yang mengikuti statistik tertentu adalah
sesuatu yang boleh diterjemahkan dengan mudah ke seni bina qubit.
Sekarang, kita masuk ke contoh yang agak lebih rumit. Untuk model-model ini, ia tak lagi masuk akal untuk
bercakap dalam sebutan qubit tunggal.
Sebaliknya, kita memerlukan kumpulan qubit untuk membentuk sesuatu yang fizikal. Contohnya,
kumpulan qubit di sini yang diwakili pada topologi heksagonal berat boleh digunakan untuk mewakili lokasi geometri asid amino
atau rantaian polimer. Contoh lain adalah simulasi serakan hadron
dalam model fizik tenaga tinggi yang boleh dilakukan dengan mensimulasikan evolusi masa paket gelombang hadronik. Dalam kes ini,
daftar qubit boleh digunakan untuk mengekod keadaan berbeza medan quantum. Keadaan vakum medan tu atau
paket gelombang yang merambat di atas vakum ini.
Sekarang saya juga nak nyatakan bahawa memetakan masalah ke komputer quantum ada langkah-langkah berbeza iaitu satu memetakan
keadaan ke qubit dan circuit dan dua memetakan fungsi kos atau nilai jangkaan
pemerhati dan operator quantum. Kita akan tengok cara ini ditangani dalam contoh tertentu. Tapi
pada ketika ni kita dah bercakap secara abstrak yang cukup tentang cabaran di hadapan kita.
Jom tengok contoh-contoh ini sekarang dengan terperinci.
Jom mulakan dengan contoh pertama kita. Pada pendapat saya, salah satu masalah pemetaan yang paling mudah adalah yang dah kita
bincangkan dengan cukup mendalam, contoh max cut. Dalam masalah tu, pemetaan agak mudah untuk kita sebab satu qubit
WEBVTT
sama dengan satu nod pada graf kita. Menggunakan nod pada graf adalah sangat intuitif dan itu
bagus sebab ia sepadan dengan banyak aplikasi. Banyak kali bila korang nak modelkan sesuatu yang sepadan dengan
siri nod yang disambungkan bersama, kalau pengelompokan adalah binari seperti sifar atau satu atau termasuk dan tidak termasuk dalam
set, korang boleh hanya dan secara semulajadi petakan nod-nod ini ke bit atau qubit.
Dalam contoh ini, dan bahkan dalam contoh yang kita skala naik kepada 100 qubit dalam episod 3, kesambungan graf
dah sepadan dengan topologi perkakasan superconducting kita. Jadi kita tak perlu ambil peduli tentang itu juga. Sekarang tu tak selalu berlaku.
Dan kalau korang ada graf yang lebih rumit atau lebih tersambung berbanding contoh yang kita ketengahkan setakat ni, korang akan
perlu laksanakan swap gates. Tapi ini sebenarnya ditangani pada langkah kedua Qiskit patterns yang berkenaan
dengan transpilation. Bahagian lain masalah max cut yang membuatnya begitu berguna adalah kita
dah tahu cara menyatakan fungsi kos sebagai Hamiltonian menggunakan formulasi qubo.
Ingat bahawa dalam quantum computing dan algoritma quantum variasi, fungsi kos Hamiltonian adalah fungsi
yang mengekod penyelesaian optimum masalah dalam keadaan asas Hamiltonian.
Untuk membina kos Hamiltonian, kita dapat menggunakan kelas sparse pauli op dalam Qiskit untuk menentukan
kesambungan graf kita dan peringkat pemetaan ke operator quantum selesai. Dan quantum circuit hanya
merupakan ansatz QAOA. Sekarang, kalau ini tak terdetik, sila pergi balik dan tengok episod 3 di mana kita melalui
ini dengan lebih terperinci. Sekarang, jom tingkatkan kesukaran sedikit. Seterusnya, kita akan tengok
contoh yang dimodelkan dalam kertas yang dipanggil resource efficient quantum algorithm for protein folding yang ditulis oleh
IBM dengan kerjasama University of New South Wales. Sedikit latar belakang biokimia. Protein adalah
makromolekul yang terdiri daripada rantaian panjang asid amino. Rantaian panjang ini berlipat
dalam struktur kompleks yang menjalankan pelbagai fungsi biologi.
Menentukan struktur protein dalam ruang tiga dimensi dan memahami hubungan antara
struktur dan fungsi adalah antara masalah yang paling mencabar dalam biokimia hari ini.
Protein berlipat ke dalam struktur yang berguna akibat interaksi antara asid amino itu sendiri.
Apabila struktur berpilin dan berlipat, asid amino yang jauh antara satu sama lain pada rantaian mungkin berakhir berdekatan
antara satu sama lain dan mungkin berinteraksi dengan kuat. Kita perlu dapatkan Hamiltonian yang menghuraikan semua interaksi antara asid amino
kalau kita nak meramalkan struktur akhir yang akan meminimumkan tenaga. Di sini kita akan fokus pada rantaian asid amino dan
cara ia boleh dimodelkan pada komputer quantum dan kemudian cara kita boleh memperoleh jarak antara asid amino untuk
pengiraan tenaga interaksi.
Dengan ini, kita sebenarnya akan mengumpulkan semua sumbangan yang diperlukan kepada Hamiltonian untuk mensimulasikannya
pada komputer quantum. Dalam protein sebenar, asid amino boleh menduduki kontinum lokasi yang mungkin.
Namun, kita akan menggunakan penyederhanaan di sini dan hadkan mereka kepada model kekisi di mana setiap asid amino
menduduki titik pada grid. Di sini, pengarang menggunakan kekisi tetrahedra.
Nota ringkas di sini kita mengekod arah tepi dan bukan nod itu sendiri seperti dalam masalah max cut.
Setiap qubit mewakili laluan satu langkah yang mungkin sepanjang grid tetrahedra. Ambil perhatian bahawa tapak bersebelahan telah
dilabelkan dalam rajah ini sebagai A atau B kerana orientasi mereka yang berbeza dalam kekisi.
Rantaian protein diwakili sebagai siri giliran atau arah pada kekisi
ini. Setiap giliran antara asid amino boleh berada dalam salah satu daripada empat arah
yang sepadan dengan tepi tetrahedron.
Empat giliran yang mungkin ini dikekod menggunakan empat qubit.
Ini kedengaran agak rumit. Jadi jom tengok contoh ini dengan lebih mendalam.
Jom letakkan rantaian asid amino pertama kita pada titik ini dalam kekisi tetrahedra. Arah kepada
rantaian asid amino pertama ke yang kedua adalah sewenang-wenangnya kerana sistem sentiasa boleh diputar untuk menjadikan tepi itu menghala
ke arah mana-mana yang kita suka. Jadi jom letakkan asid amino kedua kita di sini. Ia tidak begitu
mudah untuk dilihat, tapi laluan dari yang kedua ke yang ketiga juga sewenang-wenangnya. Ketiga-tiga pilihan akan
menghasilkan dua tepi dengan sudut lebih kurang 109.5°
di antara mereka. Memilih tepi kedua ini hanya menentukan orientasi protein kita dalam ruang. Jadi tanpa kehilangan
keumuman sama sekali, kita boleh pilih giliran pertama hanya sebagai 0 0 1 dan 0 0 1
0. Dengan penyederhanaan ini, konfigurasi rantaian asid amino hanya diberikan oleh ungkapan ini.
Setakat ini kita dah petakan tepi tetrahedron ke qubit dan quantum circuit kita akan menjadi ansatz. Sekarang kita perlu
fikirkan cara mengekod tenaga masalah ke dalam Hamiltonian supaya keadaan asasnya memberi kita corak
lipatan yang optimum. Sekarang untuk sebarang konfigurasi tertentu akan ada tenaga yang berkaitan akibat
interaksi antara asid amino itu sendiri. Interaksi ini paling kuat bila dua asid amino
berdekatan antara satu sama lain. Jelas asid amino yang bersebelahan dalam tulang belakang rantaian akan sentiasa berinteraksi dengan
satu sama lain. Tapi kerana protein boleh berpilin dan berlipat, pasangan asid amino lain
juga boleh berinteraksi. Asid amino 10 dan 20, contohnya, mungkin berakhir berada pada
tapak bersebelahan selepas protein berlipat. Asid amino yang berakhir berdekatan antara satu sama lain mempunyai
interaksi yang lebih kuat dan mendorong proses pelipatan, tetapi ia tidak semestinya mempunyai indeks yang rapat antara satu sama
lain. Jadi kita perlukan formula untuk menghuraikan jarak D antara asid amino I dan
J menggunakan maklumat yang dikekod pada qubit konfigurasi. Dengan cara itu kita boleh
menggunakan jarak pemisahan mereka untuk menentukan betapa kuatnya mereka berinteraksi. Ini agak rumit
tetapi tahan sebab ia adalah trik yang kemas. Pertama, jom perkenalkan fungsi f sub a bagi i yang menunjukkan sama ada
WEBVTT
tepi a digunakan untuk giliran pada asid amino i. Di sini a boleh mengambil mana-mana
daripada empat arah yang mungkin mengikut pengekodan konfigurasi di atas. Kita boleh tulis fungsi-fungsi ini dan kemudian kita
boleh takrifkan perbezaan dalam bilangan giliran berlabel a pada kekisi A dan B dari
indeks I ke indeks J sebagai delta N. Kenapa kita buat ini? Well, ia rupa-rupanya kekisi
tetrahedra mempunyai sifat yang sangat berguna. Jom fokus pada asid amino ni. Tak kira yang mana
ia, tapi jom panggil ia asid amino E. Kita nak tahu betapa jauhnya asid amino j. Dan yang kita ada hanyalah
tepi-tepi di mana tulang belakang melangkah. Bermula dari I perhatikan bahawa langkah
keluar dari tengah sepanjang jenis tepi tertentu panggil ia a dari tapak kekisi a
ini adalah betul-betul bertentangan dan dibatalkan oleh langkah keluar sepanjang tepi a dari
tapak b. Jadi berbilang langkah sepanjang tepi A dari mana-mana tapak kekisi A menggerakkan
tulang belakang jauh dari asid amino E dan langkah sepanjang jenis tepi A dari tapak B
membawa korang kembali. Jadi jarak antara dua asid amino I dan J sepanjang
jenis tepi yang kita labelkan A bergantung pada perbezaan antara langkah yang dibuat sepanjang tepi A
dari tapak A dan tapak B. Oleh kerana A dan B semestinya berselang-seli dalam
tulang belakang protein, ini ditangkap oleh sebutan minus1 kepada K. Dan hujah ini terpakai kepada jenis tepi lain juga
juga. Jadi jarak antara asid amino dalam langkah kekisi tetrahedra boleh dikira pada akhirnya dengan
ungkapan ini. Tapi macam mana kita dapatkan Hamiltonian daripada persamaan panjang untuk jumlah jarak antara asid amino ini? Ada
sebenarnya perkadaran satu-ke-satu antara jarak-jarak dalam langkah kekisi tetrahedra dan jarak
Euclidean. Dan korang boleh tengok saya dah kira beberapa ungkapan untuk korang.
Jarak-jarak ini boleh digunakan dalam mengira tenaga konfigurasi korang.
Bergantung pada tujuan korang, korang mungkin tentukan jarak potongan di bawahnya korang anggap pasangan itu berinteraksi
atau korang mungkin buat sesuatu yang lebih rumit. Mungkin tak jelas, tapi kita sebenarnya dah selesai dengan peringkat pemetaan
dengan melakukan ini. Keadaan qubit menunjukkan giliran, dan koleksi giliran menentukan
jarak antara mana-mana pasangan asid amino. Pasangan pelbagai spesies asid amino
mempunyai interaksi yang berbeza, ada yang tarikan, ada yang tolakan. Kalau korang menggunakan konfigurasi dan jarak untuk
hanya menentukan sama ada interaksi asid amino yang diketahui adalah hidup atau mati,
kekuatan ini diketahui ramai. Bukan saya, tapi korang boleh cari dalam jadual seperti yang satu ini. Jadi ringkasnya, dalam
contoh ini, qubit digunakan untuk menandakan lokasi pada kekisi yang bersama-sama membentuk rantaian asid amino.
Dan dengan mensimulasikan cara ia membengkok dan berlipat, kita mudah-mudahan boleh mencari hasil yang lebih baik dalam penyelidikan perubatan. Sekarang, kita
langkau cara mengira beberapa sebutan Hamiltonian ini sebab ia sangat spesifik kepada masalah ini. Walaupun mentakrifkan
arah pada kekisi boleh digunakan secara lebih umum.
Sekarang bila korang dah ada Hamiltonian umum, korang sentiasa nak terjemahkannya kepada operator Pauli yang
adalah natif kepada komputer quantum. Itulah yang akan kita bincangkan seterusnya.
Jom teruskan. Sekarang jom terokai cara menterjemahkan sistem zarah subatom kepada operator Pauli. Zarah subatom
dibahagikan kepada dua kategori. Boson dan fermion. Boson
seperti foton atau Higgs boson mematuhi set peraturan statistik tertentu dan fermion seperti elektron atau neutrino mematuhi yang lain.
Perbezaan utama antara mereka adalah bahawa boson dibenarkan menduduki keadaan yang sama. Tiada had kepada berapa banyak
boson yang boleh berada dalam keadaan asas atau mana-mana keadaan teruja lain. Fermion sebaliknya adalah pentingkan diri. Mereka menuntut bahawa
setiap zarah tunggal mempunyai keadaan quantum sendiri. Boson juga mempunyai spin integer manakala fermion mempunyai spin integer separuh
seperti elektron spin 1/2 atau zarah spin tiga separuh yang lebih eksotik. Untuk
menerangkan sistem zarah, kita memerlukan huraian tenaga mereka. Jom fokus pada fermion. Kita boleh mulakan dengan
Hamiltonian yang ditulis dalam sebutan apa yang kita panggil operator C. Ini pada asasnya adalah objek matematik yang
sepadan dengan mencipta atau memusnahkan fermion daripada keadaan dalam sistem.
Ini sering ditulis sebagai fi dagger dan fi dalam notasi yang kita panggil kuantisasi kedua
sekarang fi dagger adalah operator yang mencipta fermion dalam keadaan i. fi adalah
operator yang memusnahkan fermion dalam keadaan i. Tapi ingat komputer quantum biasanya beroperasi dalam asas
qubit dengan peraturan tertentu untuk mewakili sistem fermionik. Ia tidak secara intrinsik berfungsi dalam bahasa
operator fermionik. Untuk merapatkan jurang ini, kita perlu petakan notasi kuantisasi kedua kepada operator Pauli yang
secara semulajadi sepadan dengan quantum gates.
Ada beberapa transformasi seperti itu untuk fermion. Pilihan biasa adalah penjelmaan Jordan-Wigner.
Pemetaan Bravyi-Kitaev dan pariti adalah lebih terkini untuk pengekodan fermionik.
Operasi bosonic sebaliknya boleh ditransformasikan menggunakan transformasi Holstein-Primakoff atau secara langsung
memetakan keadaan Fock ke subkebanyakan mod bosonic yang tersedia.
Dan ada pilihan lain untuk boson juga. Pengekodan lain juga sedang dikaji secara aktif. Tapi buat masa ni, kita
hanya akan fokus pada transformasi Jordan-Wigner.
Jadi kenapa kita tak boleh hanya peruntukkan satu qubit untuk mewakili setiap elektron? Well, kita tak boleh.
Qubit boleh dibezakan dan elektron tidak. Contohnya, kita boleh dengan mudah melabel dan mengenal pasti qubit individu pada
mana-mana peranti, tetapi ketidakbolehbezaan elektron bermaksud kita tidak boleh melabelkannya sama sekali. kita perlu sebenarnya melabel
sebaliknya operator mengikut orbital yang diduduki seperti 1s 2s dan 2p
bukannya elektron tertentu. Oleh itu kita perlu sebenarnya melabel operator mengikut orbital yang diduduki seperti 1s
2s dan 2p bukannya melabel elektron tertentu. Jadi setiap qubit memainkan
WEBVTT
lebih kurang peranan orbital dalam molekul yang sama ada diduduki atau tidak diduduki.
Tapi cara kita buat itu sebenarnya agak lebih rumit. Jadi sekarang kita perkenalkan sesuatu yang dipanggil pemetaan Jordan-Wigner untuk menjejaki
antisimetri dan memastikan statistik yang betul bagi sistem fermionik keseluruhan dipatuhi. Pemetaan
Jordan-Wigner secara konsepnya mudah kerana korelasi satu ke satu antara orbital dan qubit. Ada
pemetaan lain yang mencapai matlamat serupa termasuk pemetaan pariti.
Pengiraan pariti sesuatu keadaan memerlukan mempertimbangkan berbilang qubit. Dalam pemetaan pariti dan beberapa yang lain,
tafsiran satu qubit sepadan dengan satu orbital tidak berlaku.
Sekarang jom lalui satu contoh yang agak mudah bersama untuk memastikan kita dah faham transformasi ini.
Katakan kita nak kira interaksi qubit tunggal f dagger f. Kita mulakan dengan masukkan definisi kita untuk
operator naik dan turun. Kemudian kita boleh kumpulkan sebutan dengan faktorkan keluar matriks identiti i dan 1/4.
Seperti yang kita nampak, kita ditinggalkan dengan sebutan yang akan kelihatan biasa kepada mereka yang berurusan dengan hubungan komutasi. Sebutan ini di
dalam kurungan tidak lain daripada i dikali komutator x nol dan y. Dan jangan
lupa tentang identiti yang kita keluarkan tadi.
Sekarang ingat ini hanyalah matriks Pauli. Oleh itu komutator diketahui ramai. Komutator x dan y dalam
urutan itu adalah mudah. Ia adalah 2 i z. Pastikan tidak kehilangan jejak tanda negatif korang dan korang akan dapat ini sebagai
keputusan akhir. Pada akhirnya, kita telah berjaya menulis semula ungkapan fermionik dalam
sebutan operator Pauli yang komputer quantum kita akan dapat faham.
Jom bincangkan secara ringkas cara kita akan melaksanakan pemetaan Jordan-Wigner dalam Qiskit sebab walaupun saya rasa ia
penting untuk faham cara pemetaan dan transformasi serupa berfungsi dan melihatnya dikerjakan sekurang-kurangnya sekali, korang
tak nak terpaksa buat semua kerja ini secara manual setiap kali.
Terutamanya untuk sistem bersaiz besar secara khususnya, kita boleh manfaatkan fungsi sparse pauli op dalam Qiskit untuk
dengan mudah cipta operasi Pauli yang berkaitan daripada pemetaan. Pelaksanaan yang tidak optimum
akan menggunakan gelung bersarang dan mengambil kira 20 baris kod.
Saya akan pautkan kod di sini untuk korang semua terokai. Tapi pada peringkat tinggi, langkah-langkahnya adalah seperti berikut.
Satu, guna fungsi sparse pauli ops from list untuk cipta operator identiti
yang sepadan dengan saiz ruang parameter yang hendak dipetakan. Dua, mengikut definisi operator penciptaan
dan pemusnahan yang ditunjukkan sebelumnya, gunakan fungsi sparse polyops from list untuk takrifkan operasi Pauli x, y, dan z.
Ini akan memetakan operator penciptaan dan pemusnahan fermionik kepada operator spin qubit yang mengekod nombor pendudukan fermionik
ke dalam asas pengiraan qubit dan tiga hasilkan
Hamiltonian yang diingini dalam asas Pauli dengan menerapkan operator di atas kepada orbital yang diminati. Ini biasanya sepadan dengan
penciptaan matriks identiti yang mewakili teras orbital yang tidak berinteraksi dan kemudian menerapkan operator penciptaan
dan pemusnahan kepada ruang aktif dengan pemberat yang sepadan dengan butiran masalah yang ada. Seperti
yang saya sebut, ini hanyalah pecahan peringkat tinggi. Kod itu tidak terlalu rumit walaupun, dan korang kini patut
rasa yakin dalam menyesuaikannya kepada masalah lain yang diminati.
Sekarang yang kita dah faham sepenuhnya skim pemetaan Jordan-Wigner, jom tengok ia dalam tindakan dalam persediaan yang lebih rumit. Korang
mungkin ingat kertas ini dari episod sebelumnya juga tentang dinamik hadron. Saya tidak akan menghurai kertas itu semula dengan terperinci, tapi sila semak
episod sebelumnya kalau korang terlepas dan korang ingin tahu. Dalam contoh ini, pemetaan Jordan-Wigner digunakan untuk
menyatakan Hamiltonian tapak kekisi dengan tapak L untuk model Schwinger tanpa kehadiran medan elektrik. Di sini,
ia lebih sukar untuk menentukan dengan tepat apa yang satu qubit wakili dalam model ini kerana hanya
koleksi qubit bersama-sama yang membentuk sesuatu yang fizikal. Dalam konteks ini, paket gelombang. Sebaliknya, korang boleh lebih kurang
fikirkan qubit sebagai kepingan ruang yang didisretkan di mana di sini L adalah isipadu kekisi di mana setiap elemen atau
sel unit terdiri daripada dua qubit. Operator fermionik yang kita lihat dalam slaid sebelumnya menghuraikan amplitud
fungsi gelombang pada tapak tertentu.
Jadi Hamiltonian kita mengandungi operator naik dan turun fermionik ini. Tapi untuk melaksanakan
Hamiltonian sedemikian pada komputer quantum, kita perlu menyatakannya dalam sebutan operator spin, bukan operator fermionik.
Jadi kita guna transformasi Jordan-Wigner. Selepas menerapkan transformasi Jordan-Wigner, Hamiltonian baru
kita menjadi persamaan ini di bahagian bawah slaid di mana sigma tambah adalah operator Pauli X + i Y dan sigma
tolak adalah X - iY. Setelah kita ada Hamiltonian yang ditulis dalam format ini,
bahagian yang susah dalam peringkat pemetaan dah selesai dan ia kini boleh ditulis dengan mudah ke circuit dalam operator Pauli.
Ringkasnya, kita telah bincangkan empat contoh cara teknik pemetaan tertentu telah digunakan baru-baru ini dalam
bidang quantum computing. Bermula dari yang paling mudah dan bekerja ke atas hingga menerapkan transformasi Jordan-Wigner kepada
dinamik hadron. Saya sedar ini banyak. Bahan ini sangat teknikal
dan kalau korang belum pernah nampak ia sebelumnya, ia boleh sangat menakutkan. Berita baiknya adalah saya janji ia menjadi lebih mudah dan
lebih biasa semakin banyak masa yang korang habiskan berlatih. Dan itulah sebenarnya nama permainan dan sebab saya menamai keseluruhan
siri Quantum Computing dalam Praktik.
Ini bukan sesuatu yang sesiapa pun boleh ambil dan lari dengannya dari mula. Ia memerlukan beberapa kajian, beberapa
menggaru kepala, dan mungkin beberapa masa yang mengecewakan. Tapi saya menggalakkan korang semua untuk duduk dengan ketidakselesaan dan
benar-benar terokai soalan yang timbul apabila korang terus maju sebab inilah satu-satunya cara untuk benar-benar belajar. Terima kasih kerana
menonton. Ini adalah episod 5 quantum computing dalam praktik. Kali berikutnya kita akan terokai cara mensimulasikan
Hamiltonian dari mula. Jumpa korang nanti.